if I don't think the future is worth
anything then I'm not going to have
children if I think it is worth
something I will have children we are
already seeing coastal city flooding
were already seeing forest fires were
already seen flash floods we've seen
tornadoes when big ecological disasters
happen around the world I feel a sense
of anxiety I feel a sense of sadness and
give a sense of loss so imagine you go
outside and you look up in the sky and
there's a comet there and you know
you've just been told by scientists that
comet is racing toward the earth and
it's gonna kill everybody and everything
at a big fire storm and nobody else
notices the common and you say hey look
there's a comet and it's gonna kill all
of us and people just don't seem to care
climate change anxiety as a term is a
relatively new term by no way a new
phenomenon it's an anxiety that is about
the future and trauma that we haven't
experienced the edge but that we know is
going to come our way
[Music]
okay
we're facing a very existential fear
this is not a fear about um how does my
body look or am i popular enough this is
a fear about our survival what is it
that makes you anxious what what are the
thoughts or what are the details that
when you go there that's when you touch
your anxiety in other parts of the world
they're being more affected by climate
change than this disease that we
currently live in that's when I feel
like we're not doing enough
one of the most sort of potent anxieties
is the fear of people mistreating each
other out of panic and fear and you know
it's it's more maybe how people respond
to that I just keep thinking about a
small child probably myself and I just
think about how innocent my got a
commemoration already um that memory I
have there being a child but I just
think about all the people that aren't
that don't have that that preciousness
about the world and I think that's
really that's a privilege that is just
disappearing yeah I get emotional when I
think about
the effects that climate change in it's
related issues will have I get very
angry about those I feel very powerless
I feel very frustrated I think we need
more and more people to wake up to this
and anxiety is part of a way of
digesting the information we there's no
way around that what is the part that
you can play and stretching out and
mending the part of the world that is
within your reach in the face of
constant defeat just kind of
stubbornness and tenacity understand
what your impact as a human being is on
the planet I feel so helpless but but
it's so empowered by that helplessness
that I didn't want to try do everything
and say we see an unprecedented amount
of people who present with anxiety that
they can't even locate and I'm wondering
whether this is that people are actually
picking up that something is not right I
don't think it's all I have to believe
it's not all bad maybe things will be
fixed by the time they're an adult
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon